canadienne fait l'objet
d'une nouvelle série télé,
présentée sur TOU.TV.
La série "Le monde de
Gabrielle Roy" nous plonge
dans son enfance, au Manitoba
il y a 100 ans.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Allez, va-t'en.
- La série "Le monde
de Gabrielle Roy" a ému
l'écrivaine Dominique Fortier,
dont la thèse de doctorat
portait sur l'écrivaine
franco-manitobaine.
DOMINIQUE FORTIER, écrivaine,
laur. prix Renaudot essai 2020
- Non, non, mais j'ai plus
qu'aimé ça, là.
Moi, je l'ai pas regardée comme
une experte de Gabrielle Roy.
Cette série-là, ça m'a fait
pleurer, mais pour vrai.
J'en ai écouté trois épisodes,
puis j'ai eu les larmes aux yeux
au moins deux, trois fois, là.
- Bonjour, Madame Roussette.
Bonjour, Madame Blanchette.
Avez-vous été vaillantes?
e série de huit épisodes
d'une vingtaine de minutes
trace un portrait de
l'enfance de Gabrielle Roy
à Saint-Boniface. La comédienne
Léa-Kim Lafrance-Leroux,
dix ans, brille dans le rôle
de la jeune Gabrielle.
- Es-tu brave, Alexis?
LÉA-KIM LAFRANCE-LEROUX, coméd.,
"Le monde de Gabrielle Roy"
-  Je me promenais avec
mes textes dans la maison.
Je trouvais ça vraiment cool.
Dès la première audition,
j'étais comme : Je le veux
vraimele-là!
(en latin)
- "Le monde de Gabrielle Roy"
est campé dans les années 1920
dans un Manitoba où les femmes
se battaient pour le droit
de vote et pour le droit
de s'exprimer en français.
Martine Francke incarne
la mère de l'écrivaine.
MARTINE FRANCKE, comédienne,"Le"
- On découvre l'histoire
de Gabrielle Roy. On découvre,
dans les années 1920,
c'était quoi être une femme
dans les années t
touchant, on s'en rappelle pas,
mais il y a des choses qui sont
importantes à savoir pour
comprendre, encore aujourd'hui,
OK, po femmes,
on a encore à se battre
aujourd'hui pour des chosesqui .
- Peut-être que j'admirais
trop Bernadette pour l'aimer
vraiment.
- Cette série, qui reprend
parfois les mots de
Gabrielle Roy, est signée
par la réalisatriceacadienne Re.
RENÉE BLANCHAR, scén. et réal.,
"Le monde de Gabrielle Roy"
- Pour moi, c'est l'âme
canadienne-française.
Pour m ça dans
la grand spleen ou la grande
mélancolie de Gabrielle Roy.
- Alphonse!
- Bonjour, Léon!
- Enti tourné tourné tourné toué
au Manitoba, "Le monde de
Gabrielle Roy" met en scène
de nombreux acteurs
d'origine franco-manitobaine,
dont Gabriel Gosselin.
GABRIEL GOSSELIN, comédien,
"Le monde de Gabrielle Roy"
- C'est un beau moment,
je pense, pour la télé.
Ça démontre à quel pointstrie dé
et du cinéma en français,
comme en anglais, se développe
beaucoup au Manitoba.
- Que je te voie plus jamais
toucher au linge
- Cette série d'époque est
à la fois une leçon d'histoire
et une leçon de littérature,
un hommage bien senti
à une des plus grandes
écrivaines canadiennes.
- Moi, j'avais l'impression
de regarder presque des photos
de famille, t'sais, où on a
l'impression de reconnaître
certai.
Moi, j'ai retrouvé le regard
et la voix de Gabrielle Roy.
- "Le monde de Gabrielle Roy"
sera présenté sur ICI TOU.TV
dès le 16 décembre, et
rrait y avoir une suite.
- Vous l'avez vraiment fait
pour moi?
- Oui.
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada,